I think it's working mine you're  disturbing my mind energies you can't  speak when I'm doing this okay it's got  to be super quiet just a connection  between me and the Beast okay here we go  please don't say anything would I do it  this time okay yep it could just sense  that you're about to say something and  that's already trying to mess up all the  brain energy stuff okay okay I just  don't think you can see you from back  here  should we just go around my be whatever  [Music]  Hey  [Music]  good day losers that's not a knife  that's a knife leave that look at me  look at the knife  [Music]  yo will them tech rosette Brian Dundee  yep really yeah really yeah really  why do you keep saying really  you